this unfolded in just a little over five
hours yesterday after a florida judge
who is a trump administration appointee
struck down the mandate for mass on
public transportation then by six
o'clock last night we had all these
viral twitter videos of people ripping
their masks off on planes were you
surprised by how quick this all went
down
yeah you know i was a little surprised
actually because there was a different
lawsuit i think more people were
watching one that was filed by florida
governor ron desantis a well-known you
know critic of pandemic mandates
and other republican-led states trying
to overturn this mandate but this ruling
came out of left field from another in
another uh case that had been filed
earlier by a non-profit organization so
it did kind of come out of nowhere and
like you said the ball started rolling
with these mandates being
lifted by the companies and the
transportation authorities but the judge
had already struck down the mandate
nationwide so there was only so much
that they could do if they wanted to
continue to have a mass mandate they
might have looked to the administration
the biden administration for a signal on
an appeal but we haven't heard anything
about that so
the writing maybe was on the wall and
they just started dropping them right
away
and staying with you quickly can you
explain to me how a judge at the state
level was able to issue a ruling that
had such a vast impact on on you know
not just what we do federally and
domestically across the country but on
the decisions of these airlines as well
sure it's actually fairly common uh
these days to have a district judge it's
a federal judge in a state appointed by
a president to issue usually it comes in
the form of an injunction like a
preliminary or permanent injunction
against a policy but in this case the
judge actually just skipped any kind of
trial or hearing and just struck down
the entire mandate without a trial um
and and just went ahead and made it
apply nationally immediately there was
no chance to really save it at that
point and let without an appeal so it's
pretty common we've seen these types of
nationwide injunctions issued in all
kinds of other types of situations
whether it's immigration or things of
that nature so
these are fairly common but it was a
little bit unusual the way that it came
out according to some experts i've
spoken to
well dr marjani i want to bring you in
here to talk about the health impact how
concerned are you about what this change
in mask mandates and requirements could
do in terms of the case counts that
we're seeing here in the u.s and also
globally
so good afternoon madison yes thank you
for giving me this opportunity
yes i think
you know indoors in an indoor situation
where transmission does occur and now
that the virus has become even more
transmissible it has become more
effective and we are starting to see an
upswing another upswing in covet 19
viruses across this country i think to
do away with
mass mandates in public transportation
does not make medical sense to me we do
know from previous studies that indoors
in close quarters where people cannot be
six feet away where covet-appropriate
behavior short of mass mandates is not
possible
that transmission does occur so what we
are doing here is in public
transportation where we have people who
are unvaccinated we have people who are
incompletely vaccinated we do not know
their vaccination status everybody has
access to public transportation we are
doing away with mass mandates that have
been
the cornerstone of controlling this
covet 19 pandemic we know that
vaccination is ultimately the
cornerstone for all control of covet 19
pandemic but then when you cannot
enforce vaccine mandates in public
transportation then your next best bet
is a mass mandate to protect people who
are traveling in close quarters they
cannot be more than six feet away they
are actually you know next to each other
in some of these cases so i disagree
with the doing away of the mass mandate
i'm not a legal expert and i don't get
into politics of it but from a medical
perspective i think vaccine vaccinations
mass mandates and covert appropriate
behavior
are the three cornerstones of control
and those decisions must be based on
local issues
and in specific instances like public
transportation not on a national level
well let's talk about the local issues
because international travel is going to
bring its own slew of questions and
confusion here united for example is
allowing you to take off the mask
domestically but if you're flying into a
country like hong kong you're going to
have to mask up sticking with you doctor
to what extent does the kind of shifting
guidance impact the public's ability to
follow along with public health measures
in your career how have you seen the the
shift in guidance impact individual
behaviors
so madison you're absolutely right this
is going to create a lot of confusion
and that's where tempers can fly when
people say well i heard that this is
what i have to do and now suddenly the
person whose job it is to enforce that
mandate on an international flight is
going to have to face this so you know
from many many different aspects i think
the execution of this rolling back of
mass mandates and public transportation
in the u.s is going to have far-reaching
implications and i encourage everybody
at an individual level that when you are
indoors
wear a mask if you can and for as long a
period of time as you can
because that is of course we know a 70
reduction in transmission does that
stay the case doctor sorry to jump in
here but does that continue to be the
case even when you're on an airplane and
you're sitting really close to someone
is it still a 70
reduction
so airplane is a little bit different
than a train or a bus
or any other close quarters why because
airplanes have this continuous air
exchange going on through hepa filters
and not only that the
air circulation in an airplane is
vertical and not horizontal so the
likelihood of someone getting
an infection from someone sitting next
to them unless they're at close quarters
and touching and and breathing into each
other's face is unlikely so i there are
ways of mitigating covet transmission on
an airplane which is not possible
elsewhere and so i think airplanes much
less but still possible we've seen
transmission on airplanes before and we
are going to see transmission on
airplanes again without mass mandates we
had literally shut it down
but now i think with the mass mandates
being taken away in public
transportation you will see a
contribution to covet cases in the
united states yeah i hear you talking
about the implications this has and eric
i want to go back to you on that because
i wonder how this judge's ruling
could influence the cdc's ability to
change course on masks if for example we
see another big wave like we saw with
omicron yeah that's a really good
question and a lot of that will hinge on
whether or not the government decides to
appeal this ruling if they do appeal and
they go for example to the
11th circuit appeals court and then to
the supreme court and they lost this
case then of course that would set a
pretty bad precedent for the cdc uh
going forward
but you know this really does
going to answer the question of whether
or not the cdc has this authority to
issue a mass mandate at all it seems
like something that the cdc should be
able to do if you think about it in a
pandemic but this judge is saying that
the cdc exceeded its authority that the
the law that the cdc cited when it
issued this mandate simply does not
support this um and a lot of
technicalities involved in that decision
that some have been criticizing
but at any rate
you know we will see potentially another
surge and it's possible that the cdc
could get around this ruling by issuing
a brand new mandate perhaps trying to
address some of the concerns in the
judge's ruling
for example giving the public more of an
opportunity to
put comments in and things like of that
nature because this was struck down into
some extent on a technicality because it
didn't meet this law called the
administrative procedure act because not
enough people got a chance to comment on
the rules uh so it's pretty technical
but it is something that potentially the
cdc could get around if it did a whole
new mandate if that the need arose if we
did have another surge like you
mentioned
and i want to go back to you dr morgani
as well here i i'm curious about the
impact that this could have on those
unvaccinated populations when we think
about folks who've already bought
tickets for a trip next week and they're
planning to fly with a three-year-old
who's unvaccinated should those people
be canceling their trips
no i don't think it goes should go that
far i think if you're going to go
on a trip and you've already booked your
tickets and first of all everybody that
is eligible for vaccination should get
themselves vaccinated that is by far the
most effective tool we have at
controlling the pandemic the current
covenant 19 pandemic that's one thing to
if you're going on that trip and you
have an unvaccinated person like a
three-year-old then i think if you
adhere to covet appropriate behavior as
much as possible if you're on an
airplane
turn on your ventilation your individual
ventilation and direct it to your
forehead that acts like a buffer and
does not allow external viruses to come
in and infect you so the likelihood of
you getting an infection in an airplane
if you have your mask on if you are
vaccinated even though you have a
three-year-old in front with you is much
less provided you take all the measures
that are available to you be careful at
airports
airports is where transmission can occur
as well so let's not forget that right
especially if uh like me you may
frequent the airport bar that's that's
really good advice i didn't know about
the um
dealing with your ac as well as a
potential hedge against the spread so
that's that's really good advice eric i
want to ask you quickly about the biden
administration's role here yesterday
white house press secretary jen saki
called the judge's ruling disappointing
i wonder if you consider that wording to
be that it was disappointing from a
public health perspective or was it
disappointing politically because the
biden administration wanted to be the
one to say hey masks are over give us
the points for that what do you take
well honestly it could be interpreted
both ways i'm sure that any president
does not like to see a high-profile
policy under their administration struck
down like that especially one that has
been frankly so politically divisive um
you know it in in a way some it's been
too politically divisive i think we
could probably all agree and some legal
experts i've spoke with have said that a
law like this should never have been so
politicized to begin with uh that that
he said that uh you know really people
were wearing a mask it was either that
meant that you were pro-trump and if you
if you are sorry
anti-trump and if you took a mask off
you know it just was too much too many
allegations of virtue signaling and
things like that
the experts say let's bring it back to
what is constitutional let's look at the
constitution does the cdc have the
authority to issue this
masked mandate and would a different
judge frankly have come up with a
different ruling i know this judge has
been uh uh you know was deemed to be not
qualified by the american bar
association before she was named to the
bench during the trump years uh you know
she's 35 years old she hadn't had enough
experience to get an aba qualification
she clerked for uh supreme court
associate justice clarence thomas so
she's seen as being very conservative
and it's very you know convenient for
the uh trump supporting folks that that
she got this case frankly and who knows
if another judge would have come up with
a different ruling but it's the ruling
we have and i think the administration
is just going to have to think real hard
clearly about whether or not they want
to appeal this given the realities of
the court system the way they are right
now
you